سلاحهم هذه السهام فحسب يقاومون بها ما
يسمونه الغزوه الحضري لعاداتهم ومجتمعهم
رجال التعدين الذين يبحثون عن المعادن
والثروات في بعض مناطق غابات الامازون لا
يكترثون لوجود هؤلاء السكان الاصليين لكن
العاقبه قد تكون سهما من هذه السهام في
صدر احدهم انها قبيله ويابي
محاربوا غزو التعديل
[موسيقى]
من اقدم القبائل التي تعيش في غابات
الامازون المطيره بالبرازيل تستقر بالقرب
من الطرف الشرقي لنهر الامازون وهي جزء من
منطقه محميه اكبر بكثير تسمى رينج هذه
المنطقه محاطه بالانهار والاشجار العملاقه
لكن تحت ظل تلك الاشجار يعيش هؤلاء القوم
رافضين تطوره والمدنيه قبيله باكملها لها
قوانينها الخاصه اسلوب حياتها اقرب احيانا
الى العصر الحجري بالرغم من انه مدن
البرازيل لا تبعد عنها سوى ضد ساعات
بالسياره لكن ما يهدد حياتهم هي شركات
التعدين التي باتت تقترب اكثر واكثر من
هذه الارض القبليه بحثا عن كنوز الارض من
الثروات المعدنيه
[موسيقى]
رجال قبيله وايابي يتوعدون غزاه التعدين
باسلحتهم البدائيه يلوحون باقواس سهامهم
التي يصل طولها لنترين وبالرغم من ان
لديهم بنادق للصيد منذ اول اتصال مع
الحكومه البرازيليه في السبعينيات الا
انهم لا يزالون يستخدمون السهام المسمومه
فلا احد يرهبهم هنا على ارضهم حتى الموت
لا يخيفهم
ولكن
في وقت سابق اصدرت الحكومه البرازيليه
قرارا بالسماح بالتنقيب في هذه المناطق ما
اثر موجه غضب ضد هذا القرار من مسؤولي
الدفاع عن البيئه حتى ان بعض المشاهير
امثال ليوناردو دي كابريو تضامن مع هؤلاء
السكان ضد عمليات التعدين على ارضهم
الخصبه ما جعل الحكومه تتراجع عن قرارها
وجوههم التي يصبغها اللون الاحمر تعبر عن
مراره العيش تحت التهديد الدائم وجوه لا
تعرف للحياه وجها اخر هم عاشوا واستوطنوا
هنا منذ الاف السنين هي ارض ابائهم
واجدادهم وكما يقول كبيرهم الذي علمهم رمي
السهام انهم مستعدون للقتال في اي لحظه
ولن يقفوا مكتوبين
[موسيقى]